[Musik]
top 30 deutsche werben teil 2
die häufigsten werden in deutschen
texten rang 31 bis 45
in der letzten sektion behandelten wir
die 30 häufigsten werben
heute geht es um die plätze 31 bis 45
in der letzten sektion behandelten wir
die 30 häufigsten werben
heute geht es um die plätze 31 bis 45
wisst ja noch
welches werk an erster stelle steht
falls ihr es nicht
west schaut das video
heute geht es an
so um die plätze 31 bis 45 der
häufigsten werden in deutschen texten
los geht's
leben leben
ich lebe ich lebte ich habe gelebt
er lebt in der schweiz mit seiner frau
und seiner tochter
ja wir leben in einem schloss am rhein
die schweiz ist eine direkte demokratie
und keine monarchie
möchten möchten
ich möchte
ich mochte ich habe gemacht
ich möchte ich mochte ich habe gemacht
ich möchte ritter werden und die
wunderschöne prinzessin heiraten
ich möchte ritter werden
und die wunderschöne bringt
sind heiraten
ja du träume
sich setzen sich setzen
ich setze mich ich setzte mich ich habe
mich gesetzt
ich setze mich
er hat sich gesetzt
können wir uns auch endlich setzen
setzt euch
setzt
endlich
wir erzählen uns
wir ersetzen
uns
ich setze mich wann ich will
ja ja
das dorf setz dich wenn du auch so weit
bist
ja ja
setz dich wenn du auch so weit bist
endlich haben sich alle gesetz
gehören gehören
ich gehöre ich gehörte ich habe gehört
das handy gehört doch mia
[Musik]
das handy gehört doch mir
euro und orly
handys gehören nicht ins klassenzimmer
[Musik]
ja sie war ich kaufe
heimlich noch käse wir das fondue
ja silvia ich kaufe auf dem heimweg noch
käse für das foto
ich gehöre
wo nicht ins klassenzimmer
ich gehöre wohl nicht ins klassenzimmer
bieten bieten
ich biete ich bot ich habe geboten
ich biete drei esel für die prinzessin
ich biete drei diesel für die prinzessin
mit drei eseln bietest du gerade einmal
für den hof nach
mit 3g sein bietest du gerade einmal für
den hof nach
biete elefanten dann vielleicht
zuerst muss du aber die prüfung bestehen
bestehen bestehen
[Musik]
ich bestehe ich bestand ich habe
bestanden
ich muss dir diese deutschprüfung nicht
ich bin die diese prüfung nicht
hoch
a
er musste über
übung macht den meister
dann besteht die prüfung
er muss üben
macht den meister
dann besteht die prüfung
frühjahr hatte er schwierigkeiten mit
der satzstellung
aber jetzt hier aber jetzt macht er
keine fehler mehr
kennst du halt nicht nur die dritte
person singular
spielen spielen
ich spiele ich spielte ich habe gespielt
der lehrer mauro spielkarten
mauro spielkarten
du spielst ja auch karten
du spielst ja auch
warten
ach ja stimmt wir spielen karten
wir spielen karten
erreichen erreichen
ich erreiche ich erreichte ich habe
erreicht
irgendwann erreicht
man zieht schon
irgendwann erreiche ich mein ziel schon
meinen meinen
ich meine ich meinte ich habe gemeint
ist ja auch nur du
das meint er auch nur du
bekommen bekommen
ich bekomme ich bekam ich habe bekommen
und wir bekommen wunderschöner babys
papa papa papa papa führen führen
ich führe ich führte
ich habe geführt ich führe ich führte
ich habe geführt
er fiel
und sein kind an der hand er führt sein
kind an der hand
er war
erwarten
ich erwarte ich erwartete ich habe
erwartet
ich erwarte
das alles sich an
die regeln halten
und ich erwarte einen wichtigen
telefonanruf
und ich habe
einen wichtigen telefonanruf
ich habe
aber dass sich alle an die regeln halten
sonst gibt es hier
eine pause
sonst gibt es heute keine
pause
wir haben verstanden
wir haben
stellen stellen
ich stelle ich stellte ich habe gestellt
mauro stellt eine
wichtige frage
mauro stellt eine wichtige frage
[Musik]
nein
nein nein nein
wir sagen immer nein
scheinen scheinen
ich scheine ich schien
ich habe geschienen ich scheine ich
schien
ich habe geschienen
die sonne scheint
für alle
die sonne scheint für alle
so nur noch 1
nun noch das letzte wert der heutigen
lektion gelten gelten
ich gelte
ich galt ich habe gegolten
das gilt auch
mauro
das gilt auch für dich mauro
gratuliere wir haben es geschafft
gratuliere du hast es geschafft
[Musik]
gratulation
gratulation www.hhl.de punkt ch
da brauchst du dich dann drücke hier
maike das video und abonniere den kanal
vielen dank
[Musik]